this episode is brought to you by five
bullet friday my very own email
newsletter it's become one of the most
popular email newsletters in the world
with millions of subscribers and it's
super super simple it does not clog up
your inbox every friday i send out five
bullet points super short of the coolest
things i've found that week which
sometimes includes apps books
documentaries supplements gadgets new
self experiments hacks tricks and all
sorts of weird stuff that i dig up from
around the world you guys podcast
listeners and book readers have asked me
for something short and action-packed
for a very long time because after all
the podcast the books they can be quite
long and that's why i created five
bullet friday it's become one of my
favorite things i do every week it's
free it's always going to be free and
you can learn more at tim dot blog
forward slash friday that's tim dot blog
forward slash friday i get asked a lot
how i meet guests for the podcast some
of the most amazing people i've ever
interacted with and a little in fact
i've met probably 25 of them because
they first subscribed to fiber of friday
so you'll be in good company it's a lot
of fun five bullet friday is only
available if you subscribe via email i
do not publish the content on the blog
or anywhere else also if i'm doing small
in-person meetups offering early access
to startups beta testing special deals
or anything else that's very limited i
share it first with five bullet friday
subscribers
so check it out tim dot blog forward
slash friday if you listen to this
podcast it's very likely that you'd dig
it a lot and you can of course easily
subscribe any time so easy peasy again
that's tim dot blog forward slash friday
and thanks for checking it out if the
spirit moves yeah
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
hello boys and girls this is tim ferriss
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is usually my job
to deconstruct world-class performers to
tease out the routines habits and so on
that you can apply to your own life this
episode
is a special episode i'm very excited
about this
and it is a trip down memory lane to
look at one of those pivotal moments
that you can sometimes point to where
everything
changed even though at the time it
wasn't clear
just how large of an impact it was going
to have in this case in my life
so this episode features my very first
presentation at the south by southwest
conference from march of 2007. i didn't
even know that a recording of this
existed i'd always wanted i'd always
hoped that there had been a recording
but i had concluded there wasn't and it
was a great surprise when cal newport
you can find him at calnewport.com
author of deep work and a writer for the
new yorker among other outlets sent it
to me he found it online he used it as
part of his research for a recent
article that was published in the new
yorker which is titled revisiting the
four-hour workweek how tim ferriss's
2007 manifesto anticipated our current
moment of professional upheaval so this
south by southwest presentation was a
very big deal i could not have predicted
it would have the impact that it did
i was given a slot last minute by hugh
forrest so hugh if you're listening to
this i thank you all the time i'm going
to thank you again for giving me a shot
way back in the day and as i recall it
there was effectively an overflow room
at the conference center in downtown
austin
and it was provided to me somewhat last
minute and you could get snacks in this
overflow room there were a handful of
different stages
and a number of things happened
i prepared my ass off because this is my
debutante ball of sorts talking about
principles in the book the four-hour
work week which had not yet even been
published at that point it came out the
next month
and i stayed with a friend named jason
in austin and the way i prepared was by
going into his garage he had i want to
say three chihuahuas and they would
follow me out i would go into the garage
and i would present to this empty garage
but including the three chihuahuas and
if i could get them to stop and sit and
look at me
for an extended period of time i
concluded that something some type of
presentation charisma
or
god knows what je no sequoia was working
with these canines because i was the
only audience the only test audience i
had to work with and i did it over and
over and over again and thank god i did
it
probably a hundred times because when i
finally got to the convention center got
up on stage to present and it ended up
being standing room only
because it struck a chord i mean right
place right time for the message my
computer crapped out and i prepared all
these slides and none of it worked so i
had to freestyle and just do it from
memory without any visual aids
and it worked it really worked that was
when
a handful of bloggers first heard about
the four-hour work week i became friends
with a number of them sent out galleys
and then ultimately it cascaded into
people like robert scoble taking note of
it and mentioning the book and then
shazam
what would you know
hit escape velocity in silicon valley
first
then made it onto the new york times
bestseller list where it stayed more or
less for the next seven years
and it has been one hell of a crazy ride
so once again hugh forrest thank you for
giving me a shot way back in the day i
will never forget it and now without
further ado here is the lost speech the
lost presentation from south by
southwest 2007. please enjoy
my name is tim ferriss
ferris i prefer tim to be honest with
you
uh
and i'm a guest lecturer at
princeton university in high tech
entrepreneurship
have been since 2002
and
that's really all you need to know about
me for now and i'll jump right into it
the four hour work week is my first book
and it encapsulates my experience over
the last four or five years conducting
experiments around the world in what i
call lifestyle design which i view as an
alternative to
long-haul career planning and solves a
lot of the problems that that presents
so three reasons you might want to
listen to me today
and you're here already so
that's a good indicator but the first
reason is uh
in addition to the books that i'll be
mailing out to everyone
i will be issuing a challenge at the end
of this and the the prize is a
round-trip ticket anywhere in the world
so
please pay attention the second reason
is
even though i don't have all the answers
i don't claim to have all the answers i
suspect that we have a lot of shared dna
so from 2000 to 2004
i worked at various startups in silicon
valley started my own startup
as a ceo
and my schedule was seven a.m to nine pm
so calls to europe and england in the
morning to wholesalers and distributors
the normal workday as it were and then
calls to new zealand
australia japan and then three or four
hours of email at night and that was six
or seven days a week
sleeping under cubicles whether that's a
nap or even at night waking up and
continuing working
uh i checked email
one to 200 times a day you know send
receive send receive like a a rat with a
cocaine pellet dispenser
and
i was proud of that
i was very proud of the fact
that i was able to do that and i was
part of the overwork ethic that i think
is epidemic not only in this country but
elsewhere
and
the
third reason
is that in mid 2004 i unplugged from all
of that
and i realized
that it wasn't sustainable
the average worker is going to have 500
months of solid work in his or her
lifetime and it just isn't sustainable
it's not a scalable model and i'll talk
about that more
so in mid 2004 i left the united states
and spent the next year and a half
conducting these experiments in
lifestyle design
and
what that means is i went through 20
countries 25 countries doing everything
that i'd postponed everything i'd wanted
to do but put off
waiting for retirement essentially
and
even though i was receiving about a
thousand email per week
i checked email once every 10 to 14 days
and
in the process i was able to actually
increase the profit of my company about
40 percent
so i want to talk about how that was
done
and two questions to keep in mind as i'm
going through
uh this presentation which i want to
keep short because i really want to get
to the q a because i'm sure there are
a lot of questions hopefully there will
be
two questions the first is how do your
decisions
and priorities change if retirement will
never be an option
all right
so if you are going to have to work in
some capacity until the day you die
how do your priorities change how do
your decisions change because i would
claim i would assert that everyone in
this room is way too smart and way too
easily bored to ever retire
and to give you one example
there's a gentleman who also used to
guest lecture at princeton university
named frank slattery very accomplished
businessman
acquired more than 130 companies in his
tenure at a large corporation
and
he retired at one point uh based on the
advice of his doctors because he had had
heart surgery
and within two days
he woke up at five in the morning he was
putting on his suit and his tie and his
wife said what are you doing he said i'm
going out to start another company
he was unable to fill that void that he
had created after removing work as his
identity and that's something we really
want to avoid the reason he doesn't
speak at princeton anymore is because he
had quadruple bypass surgery and you
can't do that
all right
so what if retirement isn't an option
that's question one question two
is
let's say you get what you want in the
game that you're playing let's say that
you get ten percent more customers
you get 10 more email 10 more phone
calls every month indefinitely
is your business scalable
is your career scalable
and most important is your lifestyle
scalable
and if it isn't
when are you going to become a
bottleneck
and when are you going to face imminent
meltdown
so uh i have a 745 slide presentation
i'd like to go through
i'm just kidding
i'm not going to spend much time on the
problem everyone here knows what the
problem is
whether that's time famine or
worse yet
some sense of boredom
doing something that is
tolerably
uninteresting
so
let me just jump through this real
quickly so i want to show you sort of
the before and after in my case and i'm
sure some of you will be able to
identify with this so this is the
oh boy here we go tech support first
thing in the morning i wasn't going to
use powerpoint because i hate powerpoint
but i wanted to give you a few
very basic there we go so
i'll let you read this i don't want to
read it for you
but
let's see
okay guys you know what forget
powerpoint
uh no that's okay i'll i'll save you the
trouble and i'll try to do my my sort of
dramatic reenactment of what those
cartoons were supposed to accomplish
so the first one said hi my name is
barry i check email 200 to 300 times per
day and it was in a support group
and i'm sure most of you
at some point have felt that way
and then the after was also from the new
yorker and it was a photo of a guy an
executive on his desk he has a phone to
his head and he's saying no no thursday
doesn't work for me how about never does
never work for you
and that's where i would like to get all
of you at some point
and then the last slide
was
an encapsulation of what i view as the
biggest problem
and it was a quote by robert frost which
was if you work faithfully eight hours a
day one day you can become the boss and
work 12 hours a day
are you in a game worth winning
and is it scalable i'll come back to
this
so what i'm going to do is
run through
just a few of the principles the
commonalities i found among people who
are able
to
really design ideal lifestyles for
themselves
and that entails
controlling three currencies
in order of importance
time
non-renewable
income and mobility
and this the structure that i'm going to
go through is
definition elimination automation and
then liberation
and
when i look back on my own experience i
really follow that process and it is
repeatable
and i'll give you one key concept from
each illustrate it and then tell you
exactly how you can use it as soon as
you leave this presentation
so jumping into
a definition
definition really entails
determining
what it is that you want to create from
a lifestyle standpoint and how much that
costs what are the financial realities
of designing an ideal lifestyle and
that requires first and foremost
defining not only what you want but
actually again in order of importance
what you want to do what you want to be
and what you want to have
i'm not going to go into much detail
here but
define also entails determining
what portion of your efforts are
producing the results that you want
and i just want to give one example of
the 80 20 principle and how they can be
applied some of you may be familiar with
it it's also called pareto's principle
the 80 20 principle dictates that
20 percent of your actions
20 of your inputs will produce 80 of
your desired results
20 of the people will produce 80 of the
results
so
looking back at my own history to give
you an example of how
dramatically
a quantitative analysis using the 80 20
can be
in mid 2004 again when i reached my my
threshold essentially
i had approximately 120
wholesale customers and
the company i started was a sports
nutrition company handling everything
from design to manufacturing
to distribution through about 15
countries
and of these 120 wholesale customers i
realized that
five of them were contributing 95
percent of my profit
and because i felt as though i needed to
be
active from nine to five i was creating
activities for myself to fill that time
and
the
remaining 115
were only contributing about five
percent but i was spending all of my
time chasing them so what did i do i
took all of those non-productive
customers and put them on a holding
pattern which meant that they could
place orders
but i would not contact them by email or
phone i would not chase them
not only that but i would make it
actually more difficult for them to
order now why would i want to do this
and what i did is i required them to
actually print out fill in a form and
fax it to me as opposed to making phone
or email orders i did this to filter my
customers so i would have low
maintenance customers because what
you're after is not more customers
necessarily but more income
and
then i focused on taking those five most
productive customers who never
complained always paid on time never
required any management
finding the commonalities and
duplicating them
so
in the process i was able to cut my time
down from
about 60 hours per week with the
wholesale accounts to about two hours
per week
and i was able to increase increased
profit from that wholesale uh division
about 20 within the first two weeks just
with one additional large profile
customer
and
you can apply this
not only to customer base you can apply
to your suppliers you can apply to your
personal activities so you need to do a
time audit just
as though you would determine where
you're consuming calories when you're on
a diet
you need to to know what those sources
are so really sit down and see how
you're spending your time
and the question you need to ask
yourself they're really two questions
the first is
which
what twenty percent of my activities are
producing the eighty percent of what i'm
trying to accomplish
and
you really want to ruthlessly eliminate
everything else possible and some of
those things will be minimally important
but they're not important enough to
spend your time on
focus on duplicating your points of
strength and what's really producing
results the second question is what 20
of my activities of the people i'm
involved with are producing 80 of what i
don't want
and you may want to actually eliminate
those before anything else in my
particular case i noticed of those five
wholesale customers who were making
a huge contribution to my profit
two of them were professional ball
breakers so we're faced with a dilemma
here
and that is they're contributing quite a
bit of money but there was a huge
negative carryover
i took their insults their brow beating
and it carried over into my personal
life i said a lot of anger and anxiety
with me at almost all times because of
this so i fired those two customers
and i would encourage everyone fire more
customers
and the way i did that was i sent them
an email both of them and i said
unfortunately it doesn't seem as though
our work styles are compatible
i would i would love to continue working
with you if the following conditions are
met
no insults
no profanity
if that's the case look forward to
working with you if not
best of luck take care tim ferriss one
of them left never to be heard from
again
and the other shaped up immediately and
was placing twice as much orders
on a monthly basis
so that's one piece of definition
another principle that i'll let you do a
little bit of homework on yourself that
i can't go into too much detail here is
called parkinson's law
and parkinson's law was introduced to me
by ed shao who was my professor at
princeton before i came back to speak at
his class
and ed shao is someone you should know
ed shao was one of the founding fathers
of silicon valley
but he was on the congressional side he
actually
lobbied
to have the capital gains taxes lowered
so all the investment came in
and taught at stanford business school
and he was 23 which he's in his mid 60s
now very uncommon in any case one of his
guiding principles in life has been
parkinson's law and parkinson's law
dictates that
a task will swell in perceived
complexity and importance
in direct correlation to the time that
you allot it
all right
so what we find is there actually two
ways to dramatically cut down the amount
of time necessary for any task and to
increase your results dramatically the
first is you limit the tasks to the
important so they don't take much time
that's the 80 20. and then the
parkinson's law is you limit the time
so that you limit yourself to the truly
important
okay
so moving on to
the next which is elimination this is
probably my personal favorite
time management
just a few words on time management i
don't think it works
i think that there is an efficiency
epidemic among intelligent people
especially among technologists
to focus on how to do things better as
opposed to what to do
i think there's a limit to the amount of
information that you can organize i
prefer to eliminate as many inputs as
possible
so
elimination what i'm going to talk about
just briefly
and this will be one example
is what i call batching
and and i'll use this in the context of
email so
if you've ever ordered t-shirts or had
anything printed
the cost for let's say printing three
t-shirts might be the same as putting 20
teachers the reason being there's an
inevitable setup cost involved
and that's the same with any task
the average american worker
spends 24 percent of his or her time
simply in between tasks task switching
and once interrupted 40 never go back to
their original task and complete it they
move on to yet another task another task
another task and this is how you end up
with 20 windows open on your computer
so batching involves
letting
similar tasks accumulate and then
performing them
at very limited times as infrequently as
possible to accomplish what it is you
need to accomplish
and
for knowledge workers which all of you
are who spend at least 25 percent of
your time on email each day email is
going to be the single biggest turning
point that you can affect directly
so what i would recommend if you guys
are listening instead of twittering
is that you set an autoresponder on your
email
and
one of the major keys to
achieving a four-hour work week which is
it's not a misnomer it's not a typo that
is this is possible
is managing expectations of those around
you and training the people around you
and your boss if you have one to obey
those rules that you set for yourself
so the autoresponder would go something
like this and i've used this on many
occasions
dear colleagues
thank you for your email
because of extremely high workload and
pending deadlines in a move to
efficiency and effectiveness i will be
checking email at 11am
and 4pm pacific standard time or
whatever your your timezone is
if you have a question that requires an
immediate response before one of those
two times please call me on my cell
phone
cell phone
also
if your email does not contain a
question but as a confirmation or
statement
i will not respond please don't be
offended i appreciate it smiley face
exclamation point however you want to
make that appear very friendly
thank you for your understanding tim
ferriss if you make that one change and
you stick with it
the quality of life that you experience
will change so dramatically that you
will you will wish you'd done it years
sooner
it doesn't have to be twice a day i
recommend twice a day for a few reasons
you need to let email accumulate one of
the worst habits you can get into
is checking email first thing in the
morning because first of all chances are
not many people have replied second of
all you scramble your brain with a
collection of disorganized ideas and
unrelated ideas
so let your email accumulate focus on
getting the one most important task that
you've identified through 80 20 done
before lunch so you can't postpone it
and use that as an excuse
so really elimination is about focusing
on the crucial few instead of the
trivial many and most things the most
important thing that i learned from ed
chow was
that most things don't matter at all and
almost all the rest matter very very
little
so moving to automation
this this is something that i've
experimented quite a bit within the last
three or four years
of those remaining tasks so you have
determined what your most valuable
inputs are you've eliminated as much as
possible
now you have a certain collection of
tasks
some of which are important to perform
but very very time consuming that
includes your batched tasks which could
be anything from laundry to paying your
bills to checking paperwork filing sales
reports anything of that type
what i recommend you do is really
quantify the value of your time and
i i mean that in a very specific way so
if you make fifty thousand dollars per
year
and you work
40 hours a week god bless those of you
who
who already do
and
and you take two weeks of vacation a
year you make 25 an hour
all right what i would recommend uh is
that
you outsource anything
that can be done for less than 25 an
hour now there's certain tax
mathematics that you would want to work
into that so let's just say 15 an hour
anyone that you can pay to perform a
task for you for less than 15 an hour
you should assign this task to them so
as a personal example i have an army of
about 25 indian mbas
in bangalore who essentially run my life
for me
and they cost four dollars an hour
and there are a number of advantages to
this uh
number one is
it it removes the excuse the ability for
you to create
crap tasks for yourself that are time
consuming you don't have any excuse
anymore
the second is
they can work while you sleep which is
nice so any type of internet research
any type of spreadsheets almost any type
of work can be outsourced
i have
one friend who i interviewed for this
book
who had a favorite pair of jeans
he'd had these jeans for five years they
were worn in just perfectly at the
little wallet outline
he couldn't get a replacement for these
jeans but he ripped them right down the
groin not good to wear around
and he sent these jeans to his his group
of professional virtual assistants in
india and they had them replicated
he had people his size wearing them
putting a wallet in
replicating
the genes exactly
and uh if if you go to
if you go to four hourworkweek.com
there's a there's a sample of
outsourcing life the chapter and there's
a bit by aj jacobs who's the
editor at large of esquire it's
hysterical absolutely hysterical but
this alone has saved me an immense
amount of time and
so
automation
thinking in terms of rules that you can
set for yourself as opposed to
responding in a culture of of urgency
okay the last piece
is liberation and this is
this is a two-part portion
the first
element of liberation is creating
mobility so mobility if you recall is
the third
ingredient the third currency
of ideal lifestyle design
and
for entrepreneurs how many people are
entrepreneurs in the audiences as
opposed to employees okay how many
people are employees or have their time
set by someone else
okay
so
entrepreneurs have the hardest time with
automation because they fear giving up
control i'm an awful micromanager this
took me a long time to learn
for employees on the other hand
they tend to fear taking control
so liberation from a mobility standpoint
getting out of the office is very
intimidating for them
before you can uh
automate fully or eliminate as an
employee you have to get out of the
office at least part time because if
you're only working two hours a day but
you're still stuck in the office that's
no fun
at all you just end up surfing the web
all day which
honestly is overrated in my opinion
uh
so there are a couple of approaches to
doing this it can be pulled off and it
can be pulled off very very very very
well
one key principle in doing this and
almost anything else in life is
not asking for
permission or tripping over chairs
but uh begging for forgiveness so
i'll give you a very good example uh
there's a there's a case study uh that i
did uh with a gentleman he's early 40s
lifetime employee at we'll say hp it's
actually a company much closer to austin
and he's he's a lifetime careerist he
has no desire to start his own company
he does not have the risk tolerance for
it
there was a problem though two years ago
he met a wonderful woman and he wanted
to propose
the problem was she lived five thousand
miles away in china
and he had actually met her on a a tech
support call that they'd made to a
client base in china
so he used what i call the hourglass
approach
to to earning his mobility
what he did is he created
an emergency that would take him out of
the office for two weeks he said i'm
really sorry this is the situation
i have a family emergency or i need to
install my dsl whatever your excuse
might be
i need to take two weeks out of the
office i recognize
that i need to continue working i don't
want to take vacation days
this is how i propose we do it
notice this isn't a can i do this is i
need to do how will we do it
and uh he took those two weeks
beforehand i should note he worked each
saturday for about three weeks to make
sure that all the communications worked
that he could actually work remotely and
he had the discipline to do so
then he took two weeks and he went to
china and uh he had all of his support
calls routed to his fiancee's phone
no one was the wiser and uh between
proposing and eating pig face or
whatever he did on that side of the
world
they do eat pig face i lived there for
six months
uh
he was able to perfect his approach to
working remotely when he came back okay
it's called the hourglass approach
because you start with a large period
outside the office you come back in and
then you you balloon back out so he came
back to the office he said
this is what happened
my productivity was twice as high
and he had all of the data that he had
gathered along the way this number of
extra billable hours
this number of clients contacted this
many projects completed
and he was able to really demonstrate
the data to support what he was
suggesting which was
one day remote per week that's all i
want one day remote per week you can
always change your mind which is called
the puppy dog clothes you know just take
the dog home
see what you think you can bring them
back
make it reversible if you propose a
permanent change your boss is going to
say no
just one day per week let's try it out
this is what i found i think i would be
much more productive
and uh even suggest a day in the middle
of the week to start because it won't
appear like you're trying to get a
three-day weekend
and the boss will be more open to that
and then over time you make yourself
less less productive
at work and more and more productive
remotely
uh until you get back to whatever degree
of mobility you want in your life and
there are many examples that i could
give you of this but it is very very
possible within within an employment
situation
the second part of liberation which i
don't have too much time to go into
today because i want to get to the q a
is
taking advantage of the time that you
create
so
if i only had more time
and then you have this glut of time
the question of what to do with it is a
lot harder to answer than you might
think
because
spending a week on the beach
that's enough you'll rub cocoa butter on
your belly for about five days and
you'll be so bored you want to poke
bicycle spokes through your eyes
it's not a long-term
career post whatever it is you're doing
now
so just to give you a personal example
the first day that uh that i left the
country so how did i begin my lifestyle
design experiments well i began it by uh
on a one of my many trips to new york
city taking a backpack with a week's
full of clothing and deciding that i
just needed to leave the country
and i went to jfk and bought the first
ticket i could find out of the country
which was a one-way to london
and i stayed with my
two of my former classmates
in london and woke up the next morning
and i had already set the rule that i'd
be able to check email once per week
every monday and that was not a monday
and i woke up at 10 a.m my first day
without an alarm clock in four or five
years
and
bolted up right out of bed i had
envisioned waking up to bird song
stretching like a cat under a spanish
villa breathing in the aroma of freshly
brewed coffee
not quite how it happened i bolted
upright like someone had put a foghorn
to my head looked around for my laptop
realized that i couldn't check email
shouted for my friend realized they were
at work
and proceeded to have a complete nervous
breakdown
and wander around london for a day
going to see the sites which i find
boring i don't really like museums that
much with some vague sense of guilt you
know looking out of the corner of my eye
at every internet cafe as i pass by
once you remove work as identity once
you remove job description and
self-description
after you've let your interests atrophy
for a long period of time it's quite a
challenge to to make productive use of
that time and fill that void
so that's the last part of liberation so
uh in summary
i really want to make the point that i
believe
the point of life
is to enjoy it
and that the three currencies
the three currencies time income
mobility are vehicles to achieving that
they're not ends in and of themselves
and i hope that
this presentation at the very least
really my my ideal outcome is to
catalyze a severe national backlash
against information overload in this
culture of immediacy because life
doesn't improve necessarily with twitter
and dodgeball and 24-hour access
having other people wait for you is a
symbol of power
all right
and you need to train people to do that
i was recently in florianopolis brazil
learning to surf
and uh beautiful place i recommend it
a lot safer than rio and
i was going through the airport on my
way back to the us and there was a huge
20-foot
advertisement and it was for a
blackberry a brand new blackberry model
in brazil and the title was now your
email can find you anywhere in the world
and that's my idea of hell
i encourage you
i really encourage you to focus on the
critical few and ignore the trivial many
and it's possible to do that within the
confines of being an employee
so i want to open it up to q a and then
i'll issue the challenge that i promised
everyone for which the the prize is a
round trip anywhere in the world
i'm going to open it up to q a and
i don't take up any more time so please
go ahead
yeah great presentation by the way i
wish i had the stones to fire 80 percent
of our clients and uh the reason i don't
is because we built up i own an
interactive design agency and we've
built up a really good reputation in our
region and we depend on word of mouth
how do you fire 80 percent of your
clients without building a bad will
within the community
that's a very good question
the
really fire is a strong word and
what it comes back to is
when you start a company your objectives
are often very very clear
i'm starting this business because i
want to be more independent i'm starting
this business because i want to control
my time i'm starting this business
because i want to be respected in
community ex
it's very easy to lose sight of that and
focus on the insidious quarter by
quarter
growth mentality i don't think
indefinite growth is is a smart or
healthy thing in business or personal
life
so how do you fire them
first of all you need to do an analysis
it might not be 80 20 it could be 50 50.
usually it's actually more 95 500
and
really all i'm encouraging you to do is
is focus on filtering your clients you
have low maintenance clients who fit
your ideal profile
with and it's possible to do that i'll
just give an example so i have a
distribution through about 15 countries
with with our products
and
200 to 400 people work on the entire
supply chain and distribution at any
given time who whom i pay
and i was able to to fire
fire isn't really uh
the correct term in my case i was more
or less ignoring them
um
unless they had something pending and
honestly if you just make take that one
step you're not going to create any bad
will because if they have a request
you'll answer that request but i'm not
calling my 120 customers every day to
see how they're doing because it just
isn't a good use of my time and it's not
necessary when somebody calls me like my
my real estate broker sold me my my my
last house he calls me every three weeks
hey how you doing
i'm fine how are you
yeah just calling to see see how you're
doing uh
okay i'm i'm in the middle of lunch i'll
talk to you
never
never again
i
that's all i'm recommending so it
doesn't have to be as strong as saying
you know what you're wasting a lot of
our time we have more important people
to deal with please never call us again
it's just a matter of of not creating
activities so just contacting them that
you really don't need to create
all right tim so you have a team of
indian mbas who run the deta what
happens when they read your book
[Laughter]
that's a good question i've thought
about this um i'm kind of concerned that
they're going to come out with the two
hour work week
no there well here's the thing is
hiring the indian mbas is an example of
something that i'm quite fond of which i
call geo arbitrage or geo arb so how do
you take advantage of currency
differences and changing economic
conditions to
really get the most bang for your buck
and create the ideal lifestyle
when estonia is cheaper than india i'm
going to go to india and right now india
they can't really outsource to anybody
else i mean they could try but
they're going to have trouble beating
beating the rates they're already
offering me um but it's a fair question
i was wondering about meetings um so do
you do you like have rules set up for
running efficient meetings or do you
just patch them through to bangalore
like
you know but you know what i mean like i
do i do okay okay so that's a very good
question uh
i should say that my entire company is a
virtual architecture at this point i
shifted everything in the process of of
decreasing my hours
uh to virtual architecture so i've
actually in six years never met any of
the main people that i work with now
that having been said
just general rules for meetings
the first thing is you shouldn't have a
meeting to decide what the problem is
you should have a meeting to solve that
problem so whenever someone contacts me
i've had fewer than than 10 in-person
meetings in the last five years probably
and very few conference calls so a
couple of things keep them very very
short
none of my none of my conference calls
or meetings run more than 30 minutes
define the problem in advance so if
someone says hey let's jump on the phone
to hash things out i say great
send me an agenda what are the topics
you want to cover what are the questions
that you have for me because i want to
prepare and i never have conference
calls without preparing
and the second thing is define an end
time
so it's very very common to
plan meetings okay we'll have a meeting
at 11 o'clock and before you know it
holy crap it's going to 2pm
and i haven't had anything
accomplished today so this will be my
two main recommendations
but i
there's a quote by dave barry who says
that
in corporate america it's popular to
have meetings because they can't
actually masturbate
uh i tend to i tend to agree with that
but no it's a good question thanks
um hi i think i have two questions i'm
not sure if i want to ask the second but
the first is about transparency
and i've been i have a production
assistant she's actually fantastic and
she's taken over a lot of work for me
and at this point i've put my clients
directly in contact with her so they see
me and her on their requests and i that
works out okay and i'm just wondering
how you handle that sort of like
actually amy does that kind of thing
i'm completely transparent uh if you
send an email if you want to see a a
good autoresponder send an email to
timothy
brainquicken.com uh that's that's one of
the products that i'm involved with
and uh it's very clear it says um i i'm
often traveling for business it could be
seven to ten days before i return your
email in the meantime
here are the following people the
following links the following resources
that should answer almost any question
you could possibly have and it'll direct
them to those people and
outsourcing is so ubiquitous
that i i am not embarrassed at all at
all to admit that i use an outsourced
fulfillment company for example uh dell
ships many of its products from the same
fulfillment company that i use
and uh for those of you familiar with
xbox microsoft doesn't make that
flextronics makes that
and the the
top 12 brands of mountain bikes in the
us are all made by the same three or
four plants in china now if you're a
cannondale let's say you might not want
to admit that but
i think as a smaller operator you can
actually spin it so that you seem very
smart if you say look that's not my core
competency i'm focusing on doing this
for you
and contact so and so at group x who
will be able to handle that for you um
so i'm completely transparent 100 okay
so just to continue with that then how
do you deal with say in my case i want
to increase the rate that i charge this
client
so
so how do you how do you pawn it off to
a subordinate while charging them more
well i'll tell you what my pr firm did
to me
they say no when you hire us you're not
just working with me you're working with
our team
and we're bringing on the breast and the
the breast and brightest my goodness
where's my mind i'm sorry
uh so that's how i would approach it
you're you're you're recruiting a team
instead of just me
hello um so
with your email autoresponder it says if
you send a statement don't expect really
to hear back
which makes sense efficiency wise but
then what do you say for relationship
management i mean do you think
relationship management borders on the
real estate guy calling you being like
hey how's it going
is that
i will
as far as relationship management goes
i just i believe there are very few
relationships that are the critical
relationships that doesn't mean that
you're rude to other people
but
i think that email has reached a
critical mass where people are now
ignoring email if you want your
congressmen to respond to you you send
them a handwritten letter it's it's
almost come full circle so email i think
people expect a certain degree of of
i wouldn't say coldness but
risk efficiency and email
and
there's a great panel yesterday on the
entirety of email and i can talk to
anybody more about that later but for
relationship management i call people on
the phone when i have something
interesting or important to tell them or
ask them
and i also help my clients who are
important to me
as opposed to just checking up to see
how they are so i will actively look
within all of my contacts to see if i
can make introductions between my most
important clients
i have
one of my my
partner companies is a 70 million dollar
company and they're trying to liquidate
some of their company to
create working cash for the founders and
i introduced them to a private equity
manager
and uh those are the types of things
that i handle by phone call very
infrequently so that when you do call
them they know it's important they pay
attention they don't ignore you
i was just messing with you last time
man i have a real question this time uh
you said that uh you should eliminate
what's not important and focus on what's
important
which is obviously great advice i give
it to people a lot too
but what people always ask me is how do
you figure out what's important and
what's not important you know that's an
excellent question and uh
something i'd like to talk about so
thanks for bringing it up
there's a gentleman named arthur jones
he's the founder of nautilus company
probably the smartest exercise scientist
the last hundred years i would say
also the founder of medics he's actually
in the forbes five i think he was on the
force 400 list at one point very smart
guy
and
he said if you can't measure it you
don't understand it if you can't measure
it you don't understand it and peter
drucker also said what what gets managed
i'm sorry what gets measured gets
managed so it has to be quantifiable it
can't be i think this is important
what how do you measure your results
how do you measure how your day is
successful is it additional sales is it
additional clients
what are you counting
if you're now not counting something
you're flying blind as far as i'm
concerned you need to have a
quantifiable metric
and
once you identify that metric then it's
it's fairly easy you say this is my
desired output what are the inputs that
contribute to that
and uh
that would be that would be the fast
answer
so for me i look at
what i call relative income versus
absolute income so it's very easy to
trick yourself
when you look at annual income say oh
wow i just got a i just got a ten
thousand dollar raise
so now making 60 grand instead of 50
000.
that doesn't necessarily mean you're
making more than 25 an hour now
if your hours go up you're actually
making less and that's how management
consultants and i bankers who are a lot
of my friends end up making less than
someone at burger king uh so i look at
how many hours am i putting in and how
much am i getting paid per hour and what
contributes to that um on the on the
business side of things i 80 20 my
personal life as well
but that's usually related to people so
what are the what are the 20
of the people around me are the uh the
people involved with me who contribute
to my general well-being happiness
excitement
and i'm pretty ruthless with my social
encounters too if you really want a
scalable life and you want to achieve
what it is
that you've set in front of yourself in
your personal business life you have to
be very ruthless with that type of
elimination
so quantifiable metrics you need to
identify what your desired output is
sorry to ask so many questions
um this one's kind of i don't know if i
should ask it but would you take me on
as an intern
sure
i'll give you 450 an hour
well it's only four hours a week right
well see my work week is four hours a
week because i make your weekly no no
300 hours per week i'm in a mentorship
actually ah okay yeah no let's talk
about it let's talk about it no i uh
yeah if anybody's interested in being
involved with the the book launch it's
going to be very very exciting time so
please let me know yeah absolutely let's
talk and then uh maybe i'm
cutting to your punch line or something
but you mentioned you could get a flight
anywhere for free
uh yes okay so here's
a technique for doing it or is that this
is the challenger it's it's uh no i'll
tell you exactly what it is but first i
want to see if we have a there might be
a question behind you
a quick question you mentioned um
certainly with your knowledge and
experience you certainly leverage that
in life but are there any other tools
that you leverage like you know you said
you don't really like time management
but there's like calendar and planners
and pdas and any other tools besides you
know the knowledge and experience sure
that's a good question hold on a second
i'm gonna dazzle you guys with my
technological sophistication hold on a
second
you ready this is going to be bigger
than the iphone
all right
this is the first pda i've ever owned
and i bought it a week ago
it cost me 99
it's the palm z22 i believe
and the only reason i bought this was to
have a backup of my outlook calendar and
contacts
and the one criterion that i had
for pda was that it did not have
internet access
so as far as
as far as
what i leverage
i think the most important skill that
you can develop is the ability to deal
make and negotiate
doesn't matter if you're technologist
doesn't matter if you're an employee
you're going to have to
create
the
win-win situations or the perception of
win-win situations to get anything that
you want
because the default answer to anything
that you ask for is going to be no so
how do you work from that position
so i would encourage everyone to become
a student of of
deal creative deal structuring
and negotiation i think that that's the
most valuable skill set you can develop
that lends itself to every other
so i think that like i'm taking i'm
hearing that you're saying like being
connected and constantly being
interrupted and a lot of that really
like distracts you from the things that
are really important because all those
small things make you feel important in
that moment
so that's like crack and like everyone
in this room is probably like twittering
and like you know feeling important
reading their twitters or writing
something so how do you have any advice
on like getting off that crack sure so
i was i'll tell you a very brief story i
don't know how much time i have but i'll
just keep on talking till someone kicks
me off
so i went to a friend's birthday party a
few months ago
and uh there were about 20 people there
and there was a little bucket of
cupcakes
and uh
i ate about 12 cupcakes
because it was a saturday and saturday
is my off day where i'm allowed to eat
anything i want and so everyone was
staring at me and and really thought i
was a strange creature
but i sat down next to one guy who had
about 12 glasses of wine so i felt we
were with my insulin levels and his
blood alcohol levels were about at the
same comprehension level
and
uh we
we got to talking and he asked me the
question everyone asks me which is
what do you do
and uh i don't have a good answer to
that because what i do with my time and
what i do for income are two very
different things so whatever i say i end
up either sounding like a pathological
liar or a drug dealer which i'm not a
pathological liar i suppose i am a drug
dealer to some extent
and
i told him my story i just come back
from japan i spent uh september in japan
learning how to
uh sword fight kendo
and
i told him about it and he said wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
four-hour work week you're full of [ __ ]
come on and
and i explained that actually
i was gonna call it the two hour work
week and it was a compromise with my
publisher because they felt that two
hours was too unbelievable but four
hours that's just about right
and uh he asked me he said to me look i
have everything i'm doing everything
right i have the house i have the car i
have the family i like my job i just do
way too much of it how do you create
that time
and i i told him okay
all you need to do is ask yourself three
times a day
am i being productive or am i being busy
that's all you have to ask
put it on your screen saver have it pop
up that's the one interruption i'll
allow you have that pop up three times a
day and he actually translated that
into
different phrasing which i think is
really helpful which is
am i doing a crutch activity
everyone has their crutch activities
that they sort of default to if they
want to put off something uncomfortable
am i performing a crutch activity and he
ended up getting more done in the week
that he implemented that than the
previous four weeks combined and he was
started taking mondays and fridays off
to work remotely
uh hi for most of us who work in like
traditional organizations with cubicles
and computers on every desk and phones
and conferences and meeting rooms
when we go back i mean the structure is
so locked in just by the way it's
designed what do you advise that people
do when they first get back to the
office sure okay so that relates to the
challenge so i'm going to segue into
that also
the first is i'm an extreme example
i'm nuts
i take this to
a very very
ridiculous extreme
and that's just my ocd
nature
but
for someone in a work environment
if you could just cut five ten hours off
your week
i think that it would it would make your
time here well spent
but before i even get into that and i
start lowering expectations i would say
that
the biggest mistake i see employees make
is they they underestimate their
leverage
the under rate underestimate the amount
of leverage they have
and one good way to increase your
leverage by the way two things that are
related to mobility the first is
increase your employer's investment in
you
so that the cost of losing you
is more painful than granting you
permission to do whatever it is you're
asking for
so you know i really want to take a four
week course in x i really want to have
perhaps mentorship time with executive y
really get them to invest in you and
that's not that's not a deceitful
negative thing to do this is improving
your value to the company
but at the same time it will make them
less likely to refuse requests the
second thing is that when you ask for
things is just as important as how you
ask for them
all right
so a very good friend of mine he
designed he's designed for ideo and a
lot of the design firms like frog
and
he just doesn't stand up for himself and
he was recently given a blackberry and i
was with him when this happened it was a
saturday night
and uh his immediate boss sent him an
email received it on his blackberry but
we're just going into the subway he
responded on his cell phone two minutes
later and the boss called him and said
what the [ __ ] i just sent you an email
you can't do this this is a saturday and
he said this happens again we're gonna
have to have a serious talk with my
supervisor
and
uh what i recommended
my friend do his name is sherwood i
recommended
that he increase his value like i told
you
and he's admitted to me he says i'm so
overworked because i have this this and
this skill set and i'm the only person
who can do it
sure would you have a great hand to play
and so i told him to wait until a crunch
period when he was an absolutely an
integral part
and then he made his request which was
to take three weeks off to go to
oktoberfest in munich
and he said he said yeah i'm just really
not very happy
and
i don't know what i'm gonna do could be
crazy he didn't say that but
but long story short he got the trip to
munich um so don't underestimate the
leverage that you have chances are let's
look at it this way let's say you do get
fired
what's the worst thing that happens i've
been fired from every job i've had
except for the one that i created myself
and
but it's for reasons that go well beyond
the scope
of this presentation
but
uh where the hell was i i need more
caffeine where was i somebody reminded
me what's talking about
all right okay so if you get fired
and a number of my my friends have gone
out of their way to get fired because
you get something very pleasant called
severance
is uh the worst thing that happens is
you get unemployment you take a little
extended vacation until you find your
next job everybody here if you've made
it this far in life
your genetic pool is deep enough that
you'll get a job soon enough
your employer on the other hand let's
say they lose you in the middle of an
important project that could be fatal
okay so don't underestimate your
leverage that would be my first
my first recommendation and then going
into what would i recommend that you do
this relates to the challenge so the
challenge is this
i want uh
anyone here or everyone here to
implement one of the ideas from what
we've just discussed
whether that's the 80 20 principle
parkinson's law
outsourcing your life there are two
companies i'd recommend you look at
closely your man in india ymi
and brickwork
okay
both based in india
or
some type of of liberation play
and
have until this week wednesday at
midnight and
whoever whoever implements them in the
most dramatic fashion will get a free
trip anywhere in the world
free round-trip airfare i should say not
going to put you up in a five-star hotel
so wednesday by midnight try to
implement any idea from this
presentation and tell me how it works
and that's it so last but
certainly not least
if you continue
on on the current track you're gonna
have 500 months
of work in your adult lifetime okay
since 1969 the average american worker
works in terms of hours eight weeks more
than they did then for the same income
if you just for inflation okay so slow
down take a look at what you're doing
there's no rush okay so thank you all
very much for coming
and i hope you enjoyed it
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim dot blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log
slash friday drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one thanks for
listening
[Applause]